a former SeaWorld employees claiming the
theme park downplayed the dangers of
keeping killer whales in captivity
John Hargrove was a senior killer whale
trainer at SeaWorld in San Diego and San
Antonio for 14 years he says that
audiences were not aware of the
consequences that come with keeping
these orcas in captivity lawyer judge
and host of the CBS series whistleblower
that's Alex Ferrer met with Hargrove to
find out what he witnessed behind the
scenes they performed mind-boggling
stunts
with trainers like John Hargrove you
know it was surreal nothing at that time
in my life nothing meant more to me
SeaWorld first opened in 1964 early on
little was known about the whales let
alone how they would fare in captivity
but one thing was sure the whales drew
crowds but John says he came to realize
those performances mask the reality of
the harmful effects of captivity they
are being subjected to sunlight without
shade protection that causes cataracts
and damage to the eyes they're swimming
and chemically treated water you see
them grinding down their teeth on the
pool walls and ledges breaking off their
teeth where we have to go in and
manually drill the teeth I want to talk
about aggression this is a video clip of
one of the trainers being aggressed on
by a whale and you can just see he's a
he's a ragdoll I mean she's just
dragging him down and he gets pulled to
the bottom brought up to the surface
allowed to get a breath of air and
pulled back down again how many times
that happened to you for me 10 times
I've had ten major water work
aggressions where wheels have grabbed me
and pulled me under during my career
the most shocking incident happened to
SeaWorld trainer Dawn Brancheau after
seemingly sweet moments with a whale
named
Tilikum dawn was suddenly yanked into
the water and mauled to death see what
statement was that it was not aggressive
and that he was simply playing with Dawn
no reasonable person would believe it I
cannot tell you how pissed off I am when
I hear this and she's not alive to
defend herself John claims SeaWorld
downplayed acts of whale aggression
wanting to maintain its family-friendly
image in a statement to whistleblower
SeaWorld said in part they quote provide
world-class care and treatment based on
the latest and most advanced science and
animal welfare standards our Animal Care
and rescue efforts are certified
supported or reviewed by objective
third-party organizations I knew the
truth and I just couldn't handle it
anymore and now he's talking Alex Fuhrer
joins us at the table Alex how does he
how does he well explain their whales
killing the trainers well they said that
Dawn Brancheau has pony tail distracted
the narwhal may have affected the whale
and and set it off what John says that's
absolutely not true he said all the
women all the female trainers had pony
tails and that the whales were
specifically trained to be desensitized
to ponytails so he doesn't believe that
at all SeaWorld still have killer whales
that they have in captivity they do they
do they they ended their stunt shows
with trainers and whales but they do
still have killer whales in captivity
they say for educational purposes are
there other things that John saw there
at SeaWorld that he's concerned about
beyond the whales his focus was mainly
on the whales but but with regard to the
whales that you know there were a lot of
things that concerned him that kept the
aggressions as he discusses on the show
tonight in great detail the they had an
artificial insemination program because
it became illegal to catch whales in the
wild so they developed an artificial
insemination program which John says
really disturbed him because he says
according to him they were breeding
whales and unnaturally young ages and
too frequently and then separating the
offspring from the mothers I had always
heard about the ponytail - I want to go
back to that for
second if she wasn't killed but by
accident what with him grabbing her
ponytail
why was he why did he pull her in the
whale why did he pull her in well John
believes it was just another of many
examples of whale aggression they're
just out there and he explains in our
episode tonight why that is that these
whales aggress in his opinion and and if
you look at the autopsy report you know
the original explanation I heard was
pulled in by the ponytail held
underwater accidentally and drowned
well if you look at the autopsy report
there was so much devastation to her
body nobody you know I can understand
why he disputes that Alex thank you very
much interesting we talked earlier about
big-game hunting and now here these
animals in captivity and you don't
forget you can watch whistleblowers
SeaWorld the case against captivity
tonight at 8:00 7:00 central
right here on CBS great series